i am so excited uh for this series and
i'm curious for the two of you what are
you most excited for fans to see in the
in rings of power i'm just excited for
fans to see numenor first of all because
it's it's a world that people have
seen on the page and imagined in their
mind and now many many people have come
together to actually bring this world to
life and and all of the inhabitants that
go along with it so we are excited to
get to be
part of a world that people have been
hungrily
anticipating and wanting to see for a
very long time for people that don't
know that world
how have you been describing it so
numenor
is i it's based on you know atlantis
um
uh uh you know dogeland i like to think
you know all those like legends you know
there's a powerful uh
piece of land in the um in the north sea
it's under the sea now so i
used to be have like all these powerful
tribesmen and clans where about 8 000
years ago or something like that sorry
i'm i'm riffing i'm off on one i just
had a cup of tea and i'm absolutely
bouncing he said did he even get the
best of us
so yeah um so yeah so anyway so
um question how would you describe
numenor a very very powerful island
kingdom west of middle earth um i think
just
anything that like uh your typical man
from middle earth is they're enhanced
they're bigger they're stronger they
hold themselves up more higher i think
they you know there's there's no
apologizing
and it's also a civilization that's at
the height of its power and this is when
we're being introduced to numenor as
well so you can think
you know throughout history the great
civilizations roman empire
it sort of has that same sort of uh
presence and if you know your history
well you can you know maybe have an idea
of where you might uh see numenor's
story go over the course of the series
for fans of lord of the rings what do
you think they would be surprised to
learn about the making of rings of power
is there anything that like stands out
to you the sets
the sets of the rings upon i've said
this um before in other interviews and
you must be said to be saying this
never but if you walk through given what
we know about numenoreans and newman or
if you look at the um the unfinished
tales and the icalabeth
walking through the sets of numero once
you see the set it's almost as if you're
looking through the mind of a numenorean
you know that excessive pride that could
uh lead lend itself to hubris
and you know that sort of
concern of legacy i guess by being
burdened by one's mortality because
they're men they don't live forever they
don't go off to undying lands or
anything you know that it is mortality
their death is looming so what are you
going to leave behind and when you walk
through these sets when you see these
sets you just see what men are capable
of at the peak of their power which is
what numenor is and so that's wonderful
it's a great insight into what what men
are capable of in middle earth i also
think from a logistical standpoint you
know this is not uncommon on on films
and series to film out of order but for
the purposes of you know availability of
locations building up sets making of
costumes
you know we really sort of hopped around
you know in terms of episode order so
you know for example my first day was a
scene from episode seven and i can't
wait when the series airs to be able to
point to the scene and say this was my
first day because there was a lot going
on and a huge leap from where queen
medieval starts to where things sort of
uh stand for her by the end of the
season so it it was interesting to sort
of work in that way and i think when we
air the show we'll finally be able to
you know each person be able to point
and be like that was my first day that
was my first day it's it's not exactly
where you think it would be
yeah i can't imagine as an actor on your
first day wanting to sort of step into
the really deep end of the pool i'm sure
you'd rather do something where it's
just treading water or something like
that yeah for me it was like being shot
out of a cannon it was definitely like
you want me to start where
and what's happened
okay
but it was great it's a great challenge
and you know it's it's kind of a
you know i i used the pun without
meeting two the other day but i said
it's a sink or swim moment so you know i
i'm happy to report that we all
we all swam
without spoilers um which episode of the
eight is your favorite and why i'm gonna
say four
because i'm guest saying everybody's
seen three of them that have seen the
screening so i'm gonna were there four
and you haven't seen it
[Laughter]
so um yeah so four's a good one four's a
great one
um uh of course i'm i'm
purely selfish reasons yeah um but yes
no i your best work isn't
no i like i like episode three
for me when when you see numenor when it
comes into it and stuff so i'm that's my
favorite i think
episode seven for me which again that's
that's where i start and there are some
real
twists and turns
and what's great is each character this
is really about each of their individual
journeys where they start and where we
sort of place them by the end of the
season so
each character has an incredible arc and
and introducing them to them start
planting seeds and setting things up um
there are some surprises some twists and
turns so even for people who think they
have an idea or think they know where
the story goes there's a lot of room for
surprise so i'm i'm excited for people
to kind of see some of the the creative
choices that have been made by uh jd and
patrick and producers and and all of the
cast yeah a lot of the cast has told me
episode seven so i'm
over the moon whatever episode seven is
there's must be a lot of stuff in it
because a lot of people have said it oh
there oh there is
for both of you uh do you have a
favorite moment from the original lord
of the rings movies
yes i do
i'm going to jump in straight away and
it's i'll tell you which one it is it's
in the fellowship of the ring and it's
when some wise gemge
uh walks uh stops in his tracks and i
think frodo looks back he said um i just
realized that if i take one more step
this will be the furthest i've ever been
from home
and you go oh wow it just takes you back
to your childhood you know whether you
dare yourself to go further into the
woods or what adventure you're going to
have and stuff and each day that you
went a bit further and further you went
wow this is i'm really pushing the
boundaries here and i think that said
you go we are on the beginning of an
epic adventure and that for me is my
favorite bit
um
not the most original answer uh for me
but the prologue just because
you know when you're sitting down to the
start of any story
you know the the sort of the job of all
the people who are telling that story is
to really sort of immediately engage you
and thrust you into things and and that
prologue
you know when you look at it in the
context of cinema in general to lay
something out like that in the way it's
it's hard to to think about it now
because there have been many people who
replicate the prologue but to see it
back then
it's just like wow you can't imagine
that so much story and so much
information gets told in such a stunning
way in a short amount of time so it's
still it's still memorable for me and
and even in re-watching the movies
recently it's like it's still it still
holds up it's still impactful all these
years later and seeing an orc get shot
by an arrow and falling off the banks
and the steps of mount doom i remember
and just seeing how epic it was i think
wow that yeah we're in for a treat one
of the things about the lord of the
rings is that it's been popular for
generations and i'm curious for both of
you what do you think it is about
tolkien's words and the material that
has resonated
for so many people for so long
he was he was an expert
in languages he knew a lot about
different cultures
and so it's the attention to detail
everybody loves attention to detail it's
infectious and it gets everybody
involved and you put that into a
fantastical world
into a fantasy world and
everybody's going to follow you because
the constraints are off the shackles are
off in in in a fantasy world
you can you know there are there are
things you can you can't go well you
can't do that well why not
there is this there is that and then all
of a sudden you create your own world
where of things that you can and can't
do and you're always pushing those
boundaries but it's the attention to
detail that he brings to it you can't
help but get involved with that i also
think the best
literature the best art
it resonates as a classic because at
each stage of your life for each moment
of your life when when you get to sort
of take in that material it's like
reading something and it carries
different or it holds different meaning
you know you read it as a young person
and you take away a theme or a lesson
that resonates with you you you're a
little bit older and you read it again
or you or you watch you know the film or
an adaptation and so it it can mean
different things at different times
and all of the themes are there all of
the themes and all of the the things
that we as human beings are navigating
throughout our individual lifetimes but
over the course of history as well these
are the stories these are always the
stories they won't change they haven't
changed from when tolkien dreamed them
up and and they will not change you know
into the future and beyond so
you know
uh it's exciting to get to present this
particular adaptation in this moment and
try to see what do people take away from
it what are the themes that resonate
with people in it and we sort of cover
all the bases it's literally
all the genres in one you know it's it's
action it's adventure it's fellowship
it's romance it's
it's drama it's humor you know it has
levity as well so it there's literally
something for for everyone in in the
story yeah on that note i need to stop i
just want to thank you for your time and
i wish you nothing but the best thank
you so much